I think for me the the game is driven by
gratitude gratitude is my fuel I think
most people burn out because they're
looking for money they're looking for
short-term highs you know when the game
itself and the process and gratitude is
the mix of your gasoline you'll run
forever when it's about getting a watch
or buying a new home or getting a new
pair of Yeezys you're finished and so I
see a lot of people looking for quick
highs I want to get that girl I want to
get that guy I want to get that plane I
want to get that you know car that is
just not sustainable when you're like I
cannot believe I'm alive thank you so
much and oh my god I can't wait to wake
up and fight and grind and try to win it
I love the game you're unstoppable right
I just never run out of energy because
those two things never run out the games
forever and gratitudes forever so I am
like every other human when something
ends I also have a moment where I don't
have the energy but for me the game of
trying to be a great entrepreneur and
the game of being grateful as the
operating system of your soul is a
forever game you know what it is I like
my lows as much as I like my highs
right like I like losing I think it's
part of the game I think it's
appropriate I think it's I like being
humbled because then I get hot I get
pumped like like I love when I lose it's
like I love like there's like a new game
that I find where looks like pickleball
are like smashed but like or darts in
college I remember I was like oh really
like I love the feeling of getting my
ass kicked at first because I love the
climb and I don't I also am very into my
own head so I think a lot of people
struggle when they lose because they're
worried about what everybody else thinks
and I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] what
everybody does to things like they
[ __ ] suck and [ __ ] too like I'm in my
own head and so you know the other thing
now I will say this the thing I care
about the most is the health and
well-being of the ten people closest to
me right I do think that God forbid when
one day hopefully very far away whether
it's parents or something even worse
that that will stop me dead in my tracks
real life stuff not losing an account or
not making money or making a bad deal
somebody quitting that's a good employee
that can't stop me
that doesn't mean it up and you know
what what I've admired about you is you
just have a strong internal frame of
reference to where like you know
everything that's not in line no without
bounces all right so for the average
person who's not wired that way and
they're externally frame of reference
yes will you say that they should invest
their time be more internal or kind of
like go with their other wired and some
things in there what would you advise
we're not wired like you you know I
think I think nobody's wired like me
we're all wired differently I would say
a couple things number one you have to
find a way to genuinely appreciate
yourself for your strengths and your
shortcomings
some people are just stunningly
attractive some people there's about 32
guys tonight here in Dallas that are
about to get drafted that were
remarkably athletic you know I wasn't
either one of those two and like that's
okay but I know how to sell stuff that
I'm a good guy and like you know to me
what I would say to people is the
judgment you're placing on yourself was
created through either a combination of
DNA or the way that you were brought up
and you need to spend time with
optimistic positive people that aren't
judging you to break out of that
framework glass half-full is a terrible
way you know excuse me glass half-empty
is a terrible way to live like like
looking at everything and being
pessimistic is the worst thing that
could happen to you
and you should do everything in your
power whether that is going and seeing
somebody whether that is changing your
friends whether that is abruptly getting
up and moving to Peru for the rest of
your [ __ ] life whatever you have to
do to get out of a place where you go
negative is something you have to figure
out whether you listen I'm not a doctor
but whether you have to get medicated
whether you have feel like like what my
biggest thing is who do you spend time
with and who do you consume if you're
spending all your time with pessimistic
friends you're in deep [ __ ] if you're
listening to the news all the time
you're in deep [ __ ]
and what's cool about this is like I've
seen this happen to where you built you
put on so much goodwill and content in
the marketplace to where you don't even
need to sell like it's done what time
people see you there you know they want
to buy versus people trying do the
opposite of no value in yourself self
though that's because I'm a marketer and
a branding guy not a Salesman but I'm
also a Salesman look at the earlier
question I asked you you said what are
you gonna do I said self I know how to
sell I know how to brand the best way to
sell in the world it's not to run
retargeting programs or affiliate
marketing it's build a [ __ ] brand
everybody you think my man here's where
those Nikes because they cookie him
right like like everybody here is where
everything they're wearing everything
they'd be underwear I'm [ __ ] with
this what is it
Calvin Klein it's [ __ ] brand it's
[ __ ] brand it's all brand that's
exactly right
I don't want to ask people to buy my
[ __ ] I want to say I have a new sneaker
out and people buy that [ __ ] I have a
new book out of course and here's the
best part and this is the most important
[ __ ] part in the entire game when I
ask for something
come see me speak come by my sneaker
come by my book I give away all this
free [ __ ] better than anyone I think I'm
at the top of the game free free if they
don't I understand
I have zero expectations to convert too
many people are giving away [ __ ] for Oh
when you gamble with expectation you're
a piece of [ __ ]
you're not a good person when you'll
give and you have an expectation you're
a manipulator you're not giver I give
and have zero expectations the chips
will fall where they are if it goes
great Mazel Tov if not I wasn't
providing enough value that's on me I
don't give I'm not doing this interview
for any other reason then I know that
it's leverage for you and it's gonna put
you on and you can use it for other [ __ ]
that you want to do and no good that
makes me feel that's real life and I
think the cool thing about that is from
a systems point of view that does not
create resentment within you because if
you were giving correct and you
eliminate this I have zero expectations
of everybody I could give a [ __ ]
I've zero expectations of my own
employees what many will argue with me
in my own organization that one of my
shortcomings is my lack of expectations
it's just the way I just have I'm just
overly to a fault I would argue to a
fault empathetic and I've brought it
back to create more accountability and
candor but yeah man that's like you
you're very smart to follow up what I
said by that that was a very good job by
you that's the right insight I'm you
know why I was [ __ ] happy I don't
[ __ ] expect anything from people most
of you are unhappy because you've got
expectations of somebody your mother
your friend what you did at work your
boss your homey
I got here when I'm on somebody 20 bucks
I may pretend that shit's gone I'm
giving you 20 bucks yeah it's funny I
have one funny question you know
debating whether to that and I'm [ __ ]
asking and asking I'm gonna I'm gonna
put my two cents but yeah question is
what was your payout with your dad's
wine business to build good business and
my answer my mindset dude it's the work
ethic is the grind is the integrity
financially it was zero financially was
zero when I let one you know vaynermedia
was started by me selling a client from
Gillette and eighty thousand dollar
program and that was the money that was
started the pea was Dick
zero percent of the business I didn't
get alone nothing I built that business
for my family because my family brought
me to America and raised me perfect and
so nothing the payout was zero zero
dollars zero dot that's why when people
talk [ __ ] I laugh I'm competing I
competed against people that raised a
million dollars like look you were given
a liquor store I sure wasn't then come
and [ __ ] look at my [ __ ] taxes
come see me [ __ ]
I built my [ __ ] parents liquor store
for them facts now come see me when you
got an excuse that OSE for you Gary B
you got a three million dollar liquor
store dick face go read the [ __ ]
articles I started in a company that was
doing three million dollars making
300,000 a profit
I worked by dick off from 22 to 30 for
15 hours a day to build a business for
my parents that I left at 34 with
nothing now tell me who had it worse
dick
yeah there I go and that's my thing
right
for years I never clarified that but we
said I'm not mad at people for saying it
is I didn't talk about it because you
know it was a family business I didn't
know like I didn't want to put my
family's business out there but now I
talk about it with fire because I'm just
tired of your excuses and [ __ ] me who
gives a [ __ ] what I accomplished don't
look at me look at somebody was [ __ ]
born in like the deep jungles of like
whatever and comes to America [ __ ]
Asia
my parents did it better than me [ __ ] me
my parents came here with nothing lived
in the studio at 23 years old with $100
[ __ ] forget me there's a there's 50
million people that came from Dikshit
and [ __ ] made it so what the [ __ ]
your Excuse entitlement your [ __ ]
entitled if you ever bought a $5
Starbucks coffee your [ __ ] soft if
you ever in your life bought a $5
[ __ ] coffee from Starbucks
you are [ __ ] soft globally in the
seven point seven billion people your
[ __ ] fancy your soft a five-dollar
[ __ ] cup of coffee
[ __ ] you so I don't want to hear it from
the people in my comments or people like
behind my back you're livin [ __ ] you
live in like 99% of my comments are from
people in first world countries like
[ __ ] you what your best friend's parents
bought him a BMW and not you you [ __ ]
soft piece of [ __ ] I can't deal with it
it's [ __ ] ridiculous people are oh
you're mad at your homey because their
parents their parents his parents her
parents paid for their Coachella trip
but you had to work to pay for yours you
once it could spell up
what doesn't matter with you next
vacation in it entitlement brother
[ __ ] Global Insight among all
entitled period nobody has anything to
complain about almost nobody unless
you're the worst human on earth in the
world rankings of humans you're seven
point seven billion you live in a cage
and you're asleep somewhere where
nobody's looking because that's who that
person is well let's do that person stop
complaining I think I triple s thing
because I don't want people watching
this they're like where's it going
here's my thing millions of you have
hardships but when you're in the mindset
of not complaining
it's game over my mother lost her mother
when she was five her father then spent
a decade in [ __ ] jail she lived in
Soviet Russia and she never complained
once
I just don't have time for everybody
else your mindset fighting feeling is
thinking somebody else is in charge I
know why you're upset
you actually think somebody else is in
charge I understand I don't I don't
think anybody's in [ __ ] charge not my
parents not my wife not the government
not [ __ ] anybody I'm in charge you're
exactly right and here's my thing just
go there for a year go there for one
[ __ ] day go there for one day see
what it feels like to be a church
[Applause]
it's [ __ ] everything when it comes to
another question that we got a lot is
all the algorithm changes for Facebook
Instagram I know it's a crazy thing it's
a great segue like like really is this
is what like after that whole [ __ ]
four minutes that's what you get like
that's I love that you followed up with
that it's [ __ ] free it's [ __ ] free
yes they changed the algorithm you
should have been building up your email
list you should have started a podcast
you should have been on YouTube you
should have done more collaborations you
should have milked it harder when it was
[ __ ] nirvana it's on you dick I'm glad
they changed out my email list for Wine
Library you stepped 90% over rates in
1997 because nobody was doing email now
it's [ __ ] twelve fifteen nineteen
percent the market changed tough luck
it's [ __ ] free
[Music]
and complain about free free like it's
[ __ ] free like what you're sad now
because the detox tea company can't give
you as much money cuz you're not
reaching as many people is that really
where your life's at sorry it's all
about humility [ __ ] do you think you are
that's what it's about you know why go
so hard cuz I'm humble because no matter
how good it is right now and all these
people watching I'm so flattered this
guy like all this all that's going on I
never think it means that I'm special I
gotta work harder tomorrow than
yesterday not softer and listen you want
to cash in and you worked so hard making
videos and you need a month in Costa
Rica to drink tequila enjoy yourself but
know that you're giving something up
because while you're drinking tequila in
Costa Rica I'm taking your attention
[Music]